يتهم بايدن بمحاوله سجنه
الكرامل ينفي وجود مفاوضات مع اوكرانيا
تقرير يكشف اختفاء الاف النساء في بيرو
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
هجوم عنيف شانه الرئيس السابق على الرئيس
الحالي في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
دونالد ترامب اتهم جو بايدن بمحاوله فعل
كل شيء لسجنه وبالتالي لمنعه من خوض سباق
الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
ترامبو وفي خطاب امام انصاره هاجم افرادا
من وزاره العدل الامريكيه ووصفهم
بالفاسدين مشددا على ان التهم المواجهه
اليه لم تمنعه من الترشح للرئاسه بل سترفع
من شعبيته بنسبه كبيره مؤكدا انه سيعود
للرئاسه وسيجعل امريكا عظيمه من جديد
احصائيات مخيفه في بيرو اعلنت عنها
النائبه امين مكتب المظالم في البلاد
اوضحت فيها اختفاء ثلاثه الاف واربعمائه
امراه خلال اربعه شهور من هذا العام
المسؤوله البيروفيه انتقدت السلطات
المحليه لعدم اتخاذها الاجراءات اللازمه
للحد من تلك الظاهره فيما اشارت الاحصائيه
الى العثور على
190 من النساء المفقودات في حين لا تزال
الاخرريات مختفيه بدورها بررت السلطات
البيروفيه بانهن اي المفقودات يهربن من
تلقائي انفسهن وبمحض ارادتهم لذلك لا يتم
التحقيق بشكل موسع معهن
في كوريا الجنوبيه القت الشرطه القبض على
77 شخصا للاشتباه بتورطهم بخمس 35 قضيه
تجسس في مجال الصناعه
وفي هذا الخبر ايضا بحسب رويترز فان معظم
القضايا تتعلق بشركات محليه وان ثمانيا من
القضايا تتعلق بتسريب اسرار تكنولوجيه الى
الصين او دول اخرى تقرير لوكاله الانباء
الكوريه ذكر ان الشرطه القت القبض على احد
المشتبه بهم بتسريب معلومات سريه بعد
انتقاله من العمل في شركه محليه الى شركه
اخرى صينيه وعدته باعطائه مئات الاف
الدولارات لتغطيه نفقات الاسكان والتعليم
والمعيشه مقابل المعلومات السريه
ونختم النشره من اليابان حيث رفعت سلسله
مطاعم سوشيرو للسوشي دعوه قضائيه ضد طالب
مدرسه طالبت فيها بتعويض بمبلغ قدره 480
الف دولار السبب نشره فيديو على مواقع
التواصل وهو يلعق صحون السوشي اضافه الى
طفل اخر يقوم بلمس زجاجه الصلصه بلسانه في
احد مطاعم السلسله تشير قالت ان انتشار
الفيديو ادى الى انخفاض كبير في عدد زبائن
مطاعمها وخسائر وصلت الى 115 مليون دولار
بحسب زعمها